why is it legal for there to be any
commerce at all in your or my personal
financial transaction data Why should
there be any commerce at all
in our location data why should it be
any commerce in our health day so you
think a law that said you're not allowed
to collect the GPS data and sell it to
other people or use it in any way well I
would say like take uber right there's
an obvious necessity for them having it
but they shouldn't they should have to
destroy it the minute the ride is done
and the ride should price in the real
cost of the right this notion that
they're gonna appear to give you a deal
where the real thing is that they're
gonna profit from manipulating you later
it's that there's a dishonesty to that I
think we need to get the economy back to
pricing things according to what's
really going on because otherwise you're
gonna wake up one day and it'll be too
late
and then people find that they're on
this you know they're on the street with
all the homeless people because they had
a health problem they're not in a
position to cover it because their
insurance has been taken away because
somebody figured out they were sick
before they did and and undercut them
right and so there are all these
weaknesses and I think the tech industry
should be able to solve all them and
right now if you're an entrepreneur and
you've had this experience yourself
you're at the mercy of what Google and
Facebook and Amazon and Microsoft will
let you do yeah right and you know there
are lots of companies who have had
really promising starts only discover
that their capital dries up or you know
Google suddenly is doing yeah it's the
algorithm has switched the algorithm to
take away yeah and I'm sure they're
going that that's wrong and what I'd
like to do is just to recognize that
Google and Facebook and and Microsoft
and Amazon can have a great business
without harming people and and you know
I would like to believe that the
management teams are you know are up to
that task but failing that and you know
obviously they haven't done it yet I
think we have to change the incentives
in California has a proposed bill that
would give a right of independent legal
action to all consumers so it would end
the practice in terms of service that
said you have to go to arbitration and
say if you feel you've been harmed you
can
for for damages that is a wonderful
wonderful idea and I want it in its most
pure clean unadulterated way any
situation any time and I like to have
the opportunity for state AG's to be
able to view some of these things as
criminal because some of these things
really are criminal yeah and the reason
is not because I want to punish anybody
but I want to change the incentives I
want to give these companies and genuine
a reason to reform it's just like what
happened with chemicals for the first 50
years the chemical industry chemical
companies would just dump the residue of
their process whether it's mercury or
Chrome or whatever in fresh water on the
side of the road and by the 70s the
country was so polluted you know you
couldn't see you couldn't breathe and
you couldn't you get cancer really early
because it was everywhere and eventually
the country said wait a minute that's
terrible
we're gonna make the people who create
the problem pay for it I think we have
to recognize that there are the
equivalent of digital spills that are
toxic and that the people who create
them have to pay for them and right now
they get to walk their margins are
artificially high because they aren't
paying the cost of the damage that they
do and I look at this and go so on the
one hand I want to have I want to end
some practices because I think if we end
the trade in those data location health
and financial then we can have a debate
about what are the circumstances worst
legit right right and so by default the
default matters if by default you can't
use the GPS data for commerce unless the
person explicitly says it and then hey
well we're gonna get rid of it after a
year whatever the window is to every
first we ban it yeah and then we have
the conversation okay and the reason was
otherwise it's it the we've run that
experiment with global data protection
regulation in Europe if you start from
today's thing and then we move off of
there
you know it's too easy for these guys to
control the experiment and persuade
people the argument would be you're
going to slow down the pace of
technology and innovation and it's gonna
cost customers money and my simple
response that that is nonsense what
you're going to do is redirect it okay I
mean we're going to redirect the in fact
I would argue these guys are killing
innovation right I mean they're stopping
it anywhere near them and Google's got
this bright shining
lighting Google Ventures going hey we
like blockchain and we like you know
things your parents used to do for you
and we like you know transportation so
they've taken all the money away from
the core of the Internet and brought
into these things that are more
capital-intensive
take longer and you know Google buys
enough stuff to keep the venture guys
happy and then writes them off yeah go
look at the history of their stuff yeah
it's brilliant I mean these guys really
are smarter yeah but it's not good for
the country and here's the thing
so regulation is a solution well part of
the solution politics is a huge part of
it and the thing about antitrust
antitrust in technology is the greatest
thing that ever happened in 1956 the
first antitrust action in what we think
of as the technology market AT&T consent
decree does two things AT&T agreed to do
what the telegraph company did when 83
was created which is to restrict itself
to its existing telecom market that
allowed IBM and control data to create a
separate digital computer industry in
1956 that's where the computer energy
comes from what was the other thing they
agreed to license their entire patent
portfolio at no cost the most important
thing in there was the transistor
Silicon Valley exists because of that
okay then came the IBM case the result
of that was to create an independent
software industry right by ending the
lock-in on the IBM operating system and
it created personal computers then comes
the second eighteen twelve then comes
carterfone which basically gets the AT&T
telecom hardware into the public domain
so people could make telephone stuff
yeah you don't pick from three at the
phone store and then you go to the
second of 18t breakup which brings
cellular forward like ten years and I
don't even know how much it brought
broadband data but they weren't even
thinking about broadband and that became
a big deal and then Microsoft which
leads to the internet and what's here's
the punchline every one of the target
companies so 18t several times IBM
Microsoft went to all-time highs four
years after the thing and in the country
cause well because the the business they
were left with was still incredibly
attractive and the tide rose forever
yet we created whole new industries yeah
and my point here is which they got to
participate in and had a pole position
on it well in some cases right in a TT
they couldn't participate in computers
right but but but in Microsoft's case
they could participate in the internet
they they did so we've been nicer to
Microsoft than we were to some of you
and IBM participate in PCs obviously so
so at the end of the day my simple
observation here is I am incredibly Pro
Tech and pro-growth I just think we're
in a place we've been before this is it
looks these guys are the new robber
barons right yeah they've defined a
world that suits them and I think when
you study it economically you see that
that they behave they live in Annapolis
behave not because they're bad people
but because the economic imperatives of
monopolies are that you restrict
innovation and you restrict you know all
kinds of things and I think the country
is better served when we have rampant
entrepreneurship and we have rampant
growth and these guys are preventing
that from happening